life is stressful play makes it fun
psychologists increasingly believe that
play holds the key to True productivity
partly because it provides a sense of
psychological relief at least six Nobel
Prize winners attribute their success to
play James Watson and Francis Crick who
discovered the structure of DNA in the
1950s described the generative process
they used to come up with the structure
as constructing a set of molecular
models and beginning to play Alexander
Fleming the scientist who discovered the
antibiotic penicillin once described his
job as playing with microbes Donna
Strickland the 2018 Nobel laurate in
physics described her career as getting
to play with high-intensity lasers
Constantine novoselov who shared the
2010 Nobel Prize in physics for helping
discovered graphine put it most simply
if you try to win the Nobel you won't he
reflected the way we were working really
was quite playful if we can integrate
the spirit of play into our lives we'll
feel better and do more too